today's episode of the y-files is
brought to you by established titles
what if you offered the opportunity to
visit another planet you'd get to
experience the culture of an alien race
explore a new world cnu's technology
that's 5 000 years ahead of ours would
you do it well before you answer there
are a few catches you'll be gone at
least 10 years and when you return to
Earth all evidence of your existence
will be erased you have to start a new
life with a new identity forbidden to
tell anyone about what you experienced
now would you do it well 1965 12
astronauts were sent to an alien planet
as part of a human alien Exchange
program 13 years later they returned
home well most of them did the mission
Commander wrote a 3000 page report of
everything the team experienced first
alien contact the 40 light-year trip to
the alien world and everything that
happened on the planet this is the true
story of project Serpa
[Music]
when Colonel McKeever of the United
States Air Force arrived at Fort
Leavenworth he was excited but he didn't
have much information all he knew is
that he was selected from hundreds of
candidates to command the most important
space mission in the history of the
human race that's quite a description
naturally he asked for details about the
mission but was told he would be brief
during training McKeever did know the
mission was going to be long 10 years
plus almost a year for training and
another year in quarantine at the end of
the mission so 12 years away from home
it was 1965 so he wouldn't be back until
the late 70s
now for most people this would be
difficult but McKeever had no relatives
no wife no kids and very few friends his
life was the Air Force as far as he was
concerned he could leave for 12 years or
20 was all the same to him and that was
a good thing because another condition
of the mission is that he was to be
shape-dipped sheep dipped well sheep
dipped is an intelligence term used to
describe identities that are made to
disappear all records military civilian
school records Social Security DMV IRS
it's like you never existed you I
wouldn't mind disappearing from the IRS
I understand that tax is a theft Colonel
McKeever parked his car and was met by a
young military police officer after
exchanging salutes they walked in
silence to an office building at the
edge of the base the outside of the
building was non-descript painted that
gray green beige color that the military
used for everything the inside of the
building was very different though as a
colonel McKeever had been in plenty of
secure buildings but nothing like this
metal detectors cameras everywhere armed
guards posted in every hallway
mckeever's escort motioned to an
elevator McKeever asked you're not
coming with me the young man said no he
didn't have clearance he saluted and the
elevator doors closed McKeever felt the
elevator taking him several stories down
he noticed there were no buttons in the
elevator no indication of the number of
floors the elevator doors opened and
another young man was waiting McKeever
noticed his badge said Air Force office
of special investigations as far as
Colonel McKeever knew OSI was a law
enforcement agency he had no idea what
they would be doing here but he knew not
to ask McKeever entered The Briefing
room which looked like a classroom there
were 11 people seated he saw two army
uniforms two Navy and the rest were Air
Force at the front of the room was
another Air Force Colonel that mccaver
didn't recognize who told him to take a
seat the other Colonel said to the group
what I'm about to show you is classified
Beyond top secret there are fewer than
60 people in the world who know this
information if you repeat what you learn
here today you'll be charged with
treason understood the group nodded
slowly clearly aware of the weight of
the situation the colonel pulled down a
screen and called to someone to get the
lights on the screen a black and white
film began to play the first few seconds
were the typical warnings about
unauthorized viewing and other
disclaimers that Colonel McKeever had
seen a thousand times the footage showed
what appeared to be the desert at night
though it was hard to tell the footage
seemed to be 20 years old then a title
came on the screen that McKeever didn't
expect it read Roswell New Mexico 1947
first Contact
the film lasted about an hour and left
everyone in the room stunned they had
heard of Roswell and the supposed UFO
crash the Air Force said it was a
weather balloon and that explanation was
good enough for McKeever the film
explained that the UFO crash in Roswell
did happen though technically the crash
was in Corona New Mexico and two years
later in 1949 another UFO crash nearby
this was something McKeever didn't know
and there was footage of the Roswell
recovery at first it was difficult to
understand what he was looking at it was
clearly metal wreckage but it could have
been a plane for all McKeever knew then
he saw it hiding behind a rock was an
alien it looked like aliens look in
science fiction movies short pale skin
large head with huge black eyes small
nose and mouth the military called this
creature extraterrestrial biological
entity one or Eva one Eva one was the
Lone Survivor of the crash five other
alien bodies were taken away there was
also footage of the 1949 crash it was a
similar craft so silver saucer shaped
there were six bodies there and no
survivors Eva one was taken to the Air
Force facility at Los Alamos and
according to the briefing he stayed
there until his death in 1952. the Air
Force learned a great deal from Eva one
in those five years at First
Communication was difficult everyone's
language was comprised of tones not
words but through hand gestures and
repetition Eva one was able to
communicate he said that his race which
the military called the ebens had been
visiting Earth for 2 000 years on this
trip something caused his ship to crash
Eva one suspected it was radar which was
a technology his people didn't have some
equipment was salvaged from Evil one's
craft specifically a communication
device evil one offered to share this
technology if the military would allow
him to repair it so he could contact his
people of course the military agreed
even one was able to get the
communicator working again and sent
several messages but never received a
reply and this could have been due to a
number of reasons evil one's home planet
which the military called serpo was in
The Zeta reticuli system almost 40 light
years from Earth the ebens used Wormhole
technology to travel and send messages
back and forth after evil one died in
1952 the Air Force tried but was unable
to reverse engineer other alien
technology but they did have a working
Communicator so the Air Force continued
to send messages for years the
persistence paid off eventually they
received a reply and two-way
communication between Earth and serpo
continued for a long time the evens even
learned to speak broken English after
learning about the crashes The ebens
Wanted their crew's bodies back but the
military being the military wanted
something in exchange let me guess they
wanted technology yep but they even said
it would be too dangerous to give humans
their technology well I could have told
them that so they even suggested a
compromise the military would return the
bodies of the alien crew in exchange and
even would come to Earth and assist the
US Army and 12 humans could spend 10
years on planet Serpa this became known
as project serpo though its actual name
is Project Crystal Knight and so began
the first Intergalactic Exchange program
in history
the training was intense and long a year
Colonel McKeever thought Special Forces
had a difficult training program but it
was nothing like this there were the
usual physical exercises and classroom
training they trained in survival escape
and evasion techniques weapons
explosives and intelligence gathering
they also learned about even history and
even biology but there was aggressive
and invasive psychological training and
testing McKeever remembered one
unusually difficult exercise designed to
test the team's ability to cope with
isolation and confined spaces team
members were buried seven feet
underground one at a time in a seven by
five foot box for five days no lights no
way to communicate only a small air hole
and food and water everybody passed this
test but some people really struggled
with it oh come on five by seven feet is
a tell us tell us Grill up here during
training McKeever got to know his team
there were scientists linguists Pilots
two doctors and a security officer they
all received General training and
training geared toward their specialty
for example the pilots were taught how
to fly an even aircraft this was
surprisingly easy and apparently a lot
of fun the evens returned to Earth in
1964 to retrieve the bodies this
happened at Holloman Air Force Base in
New Mexico there's actually footage of
that Landing
[Music]
[Laughter]
about a year later in July 1965 the team
traveled to groom lake near Area 51 for
the landing at 6 a.m the even ship
landed several evens came out to meet
the team of 12 and about 16 military
officials the human team was allowed to
bring whatever they needed for the stay
they brought 40 tons of gear including
10 motorcycles and three Jeeps
everything was easily loaded using
anti-gravity technology now lucky for us
McKeever was ordered to keep diary okay
we loaded everything and it fits but we
have to transfer all of it to the bigger
ship once we get to the Rendezvous Point
really excited about this No
Reservations by anyone the training
Commander asked all members to make
final decision the team all said go we
go interior of Eva craft is Big there
are three levels this is different than
the one we trained on I think that was a
Scout craft this one is a shuttle craft
the shuttle flew into a large ship
McKeever wrote that the shuttle base
ceiling was about a hundred feet high it
would take almost 10 months to get to
Serpa the human team was escorted to the
area where they would be spending the
next 270 days each team member was
assigned a small pod each with a single
chair no seat belts or harnesses
McKeever was surprised that gravity was
consistent he was expecting to be
weightless then he saw a Light Panel
change from white to Red he assumed this
meant they were moving his eyes became
blurry the room started to spin and then
he blacked out
foreign
the journey was difficult the human team
spent a large part of 10 months sick
they would often become dizzy and
sometimes physically ill during one part
of the journey and even gave the humans
a cloudy liquid that tasted like chalk
and a cookie or a biscuit that had no
taste at all but when they ate it they
felt better almost instantly after a
while the human team was allowed to move
around the ship we were able to walk
around the ship but it's so large it's
difficult to understand how such a large
ship can move so fast 633 wants to see
the engines our guide takes four of us
to the engine room or whatever they wish
to call the road it contains large very
large metal containers they are in a
circle with the ends of each pointing
into the center many pipes are some type
of large tubes connects them in the
center of these containers is a copper
colored coil or something looking like a
coil there's a bright light being shined
from a point above into the center of
the coil we hear a very dull hum but no
major loud sounds 66 61 thinks it is a
negative matter versus positive matter
system one day toward the end of the
journey McKeever got out of his pod and
asked the assistant Commander team
member 203 to round up the team 203 yep
team members were now required to refer
to each other by their number and not
their name oh cause they were dipped in
the air the Sheep thing cheap dipped so
two or three rounds of the team but
there's a problem one of the pilots team
member 308 is missing McKeever asked
what happened to 308 one of the even
says Earth man not alive McKeever asked
to see him but they even say that's not
possible the security officer team
member 899 says I'm going to get the
guns part of the gear the human team
brought included weapons they were each
issued a rifle they had handguns they
also had grenades and C4 explosives 899
begins to storm off when a female Eben
who speaks very good English says please
no guns she explains that 308's body is
in quarantine until they can figure out
what happened the evens allow the human
doctors 700 and 754 to examine the body
they determined 308 died from an
embolism but they evens want him to
remain quarantined McKeever agrees as
long as 308 can be given a proper burial
on serpo not long after that the humans
are instructed to return to their pods
and prepare for landing which they do
there must be something about jumping in
and out of a wormhole that's hard on
human anatomy because McKeever blacks
out again boy this guy really can't hold
his wormhole
six hours later his pot opens and his
team walks to the door slowly the door
opens
[Music]
the door opens and bright light washes
into the craft the team members were
issued heavy duty sunglasses like those
worn during nuclear bomb tests they
quickly put them on the first thing
McKeever noticed was the heat he asked
one of the scientists team member 633 to
check the temperature 107 degrees
Fahrenheit the landscape is Barren there
are Hills in the distance but no
vegetation just soil and rock and blue
sky above McKeever thinks it looks like
Arizona or New Mexico one major
difference two suns in the sky
mckeever's report supposedly has several
thousand photographs and even film
unfortunately these haven't been leaked
except for one photo the two sons of
serpo
serpo is in the Zeta reticuli binary
star system because of its two sons
serpo is never in complete darkness
according to the report serpo has one
main Sun that the planet orbits the
second sun is farther away a large
number of evens have gathered for the
arrival brawl a little over four feet
tall and the human team can't really
tell them apart unless they're wearing
different clothing a female even who
they designate Eva to introduces herself
as translator and guide the human team
is escorted through an even Village to
where they'll be staying and for a
technologically advanced species the way
the evens live appears somewhat
primitive there are only about 650 000
evens on the planet who live in small
communities at the center of each
Community is a large Tower about 300
feet high on top of the tower is what
looks like a mirror the humans learned
that this Tower is how evens tell time
this was a difficult adjustment because
the even day is 40 hours long not 24 and
with their never being Darkness it was
hard to adapt their schedules even
families were similar to Earth's
typically a female and a male with two
children families were only allowed to
have two children and children were
rarely seen they mature very quickly and
are isolated while they're young they
even homes were small domes that
reminded the team of adobe houses in the
southwest the humans finally arrive at
their accommodations
the two leads us to a series of Huts
looking like Adobe style houses there
are four behind them is an underground
room or storage area it is built into
the ground underground we have to walk
down a ramp the doors look like military
igloos that store our atomic bombs in
Earth all our gear taken off the
spaceship is stored there we walked down
into this area very large room very cool
a lot cooler we might have to sleep here
all our gear is there 16 pallets of gear
this Igloo is made up of something like
concrete but not the same texture feels
like soft rubber but still hard the
floor is made up of the same stuff there
are lights in the ceiling looks like
spotlights they have electricity each
home was equipped with an electrical
device that looks like a small piece of
plexiglass no matter what's connected to
it the device outputs the correct amount
of voltage these devices could power a
small handheld radio or an entire home
without a problem supposedly one of
these devices was recovered from Roswell
but scientists haven't been able to
reverse engineer this technology
allegedly right now that they're finally
on the planet McKeever requests the body
of team member 308 so they can give him
a proper burial Eva one takes McKeever
to a building that looks like a medical
facility and even doctor meets them at
the door he speaks English almost
perfectly McKeever says he wants 308's
body even doctors confused he says you
can't have him McKeever says give us our
man or we'll take him by force ebitu
jumps in she says it's not that they
don't want to return 308's body it's
that they can't the doctor confirms this
and says we're using him McKeever asks
what he means the doctor casually says
well we're cloning him and using him to
create hybrids
foreign
obviously cloning a member of the team
without permission was a problem but
McKeever heard the doctor out when even
it was considered a great honor to
donate your body to science for
experimentation and cloning McKeever
doubted he could do much about the
situation the evens were peaceful but
they did have a military if they wanted
to put the humans in prison or Worse
McKeever knew there wasn't much he could
do about it we were only 11 military
personnel we had no way of fighting the
evens if we did not come 40 light years
to start a war with the events a war we
could not win we could not even win a
simple fist fight with Edens even if we
could what then so with the help of Eva
2 the doctor agrees that 308's body will
not be used anymore not that it mattered
much the doctor said all of 308's blood
organs tissue and everything was used to
create new creatures McKeever said show
me in a small anti-gravity aircraft the
human team was flown to a laboratory
facility the inside of the building was
completely white there were a lot of
Even's walking around all wearing blue
clothing when they were brought to the
first lab
there were rolls of containers looking
like glass bathtubs inside each bathtub
were bodies I was shocked as were
7754 bodies strange looking bodies not
human bodies at least not all of them we
started walking down the space between
the tubs we looked into the tubs these
were hideous looking creatures
the first creature I see inside the tub
looks like a porcupine it appears to
have a tube placed inside of it the tube
leads to a box underneath the tub the
next creature looks like nothing I can
compare it to it has blood red skin two
spots in the middle maybe eyes no arms
or legs it had a very strange odor the
next creature was human-like but the
skin was white not skin white the color
white the skin was wrinkled the head was
large with two eyes two ears and a mouth
the neck was very small the head looked
almost as if it sat on the lower torso
the chest was thin with large bone-like
protrusions the arms were curled with
hands but no thumbs the legs were also
curled with feet but only three toes I
couldn't look at any more creatures next
they went to what the doctor called a
growing room here they used parts of
different species including parts of the
dead human to create new species Eva 2
said that parts of the blood and other
organs are used to mix a substance
that's placed inside the bodies that was
all Eva 2 could explain in English they
were breathing they look like humans
most of them two of the beings on the
end look like humans with dog heads
these beings were not awake they were
either sleeping or drugged they finally
arrived at a growing chamber that
contained an entity that was created
using parts of 308's body I was shocked
this being with our teammates blood and
cells look like a large even but the
hands and legs were similar to humans
how could they have grown this being so
quick obviously this is well above our
intelligence I saw all I wanted to see I
told the doctor that we would like to
leave Eva two saw that I was upset and
touched my hand instantly I felt
concerned
we traveled outside this building a
building that I did not wish to see
again I saw the dark side of this
civilization the evens are not the
Humane civilization we thought they were
[Music]
because of the misunderstanding of even
time the 10-year mission was actually 13
years during that time McKeever and his
team learned a lot about even culture
even life was very regimented as
children mature they're tested for
aptitude and placed in jobs to which
they're most suited all evens work part
of the day they rest part of the day and
even pray part of the day though the
team never could figure out what kind of
religion or spiritual beliefs they had
all manufacturing took place away from
the even homes same with agriculture
evens grew all their food hydroponically
the human team had taken about two years
worth of food with them and when that
ran out they tried to get accustomed to
even food which wasn't easy everything
tasted like paper or chalk ooh it sounds
like they learned how to cook for my
second wife the cooking was terrible how
bad was it her cooking was so bad we
prayed after the meal good one no I tell
you her cooking was bad how bad was it
her cooking was so bad the Flies shipped
in for a screen door
the cooking was bad how bad was it her
cooking was so bad I
was in the kitchen and
evens are vegetarian but the humans
wanted meat and there were animals on
the planet as I mentioned before the
evens allowed us to kill the beasts for
meat the meat isn't really bad 8.99 says
it tastes like bear which I never ate
but evens look at us very strange when
we eat meat they allow us to do just
about anything we want and eating meat
is something we need for the protein we
use the last of our salt and pepper
which does make eating their food more
of a challenge the evens don't have
anything similar they do have an herb as
we call it something like oregano which
they use it has a tart taste but we have
developed a taste for it the ebens don't
use money all evens are required to work
their assigned job and contribute to the
community there was a council of
Governors that controlled every single
activity and every minute detail of the
evens lives food clothing Furniture
everything is supplied they evens go to
a central distribution center and make a
request and were given anything that
they need you know I noticed every time
time we do an alien story they turn out
to be hippie Communists well maybe it's
a better way of life oh yeah better for
the people in charge
the humans noticed they were getting a
heavy dose of radiation from the two
sons and the heat was unbearable it was
consistently 120 to 130 degrees
eventually the humans were allowed to
move further north the climate was much
more comfortable there in the 60s and
70s and it was actually green this
environment didn't suit the evens but
the humans loved it after 13 years the
mission ended and eight of the 12 team
members returned 308 died on the way and
a pilot died in a vehicle crash two team
members decided to stay on serpo when
the remaining team members returned to
Earth they were quarantined and
debriefed for an entire year they were
given new identities and large cash
bonuses six team members retired and two
returned to active duty most of the team
developed illnesses due to the high dose
of radiation they received on the planet
and died pretty young Colonel McKeever
the last surviving team member retired
to Florida he passed away in 2002 but he
leaves what is perhaps the most
important Legacy in human history a 3
000 page report detail every aspect of
traveling to and living on an alien
planet yet there are no monuments to him
no statues no schools or Street Spare
his name Colonel McKeever volunteered
for this Dangerous Mission not for
personal Glory but in service to all
Americans and the entire human race
maybe one day he'll be recognized as a
great man but sadly that day is not
today
the project serpo story has become
legendary in the UFO Community it's
firmly part of the lore but is it real
to get to the truth of the serpo story
there is a lot to unravel and there are
a couple of theories the project serpo
Saga began in November 2005 when someone
named request Anonymous emailed Victor
Martinez who ran a UFO mailing list
Anonymous said he was a retired U.S
government employee who is involved in a
special program over the next nine
months he detailed the story you heard
today in the description I'll link to a
PDF of all his emails it's 130 pages and
covers every possible detail you can
think of the anonymous emails caused all
kinds of drama there was infighting
accusations threats and even a little
bit of blackmail the fighting all came
down to was Anonymous telling the truth
and if not who was he and why was he
doing this after some excellent
sleuthing from a couple of tech savvy
mailing list members at least five
separate email accounts including
Anonymous were traced back to one man
the infamous Richard Dodie this guy
again yep if you've seen our episodes
about Paul benowitz and Dulce bass
you'll be familiar with the name Dodie
was an Air Force intelligence agent who
specialized in spreading UFO
disinformation he specifically targeted
Paul benowitz an Albuquerque businessman
who thought he was intercepting messages
from Aliens Dodie also used respected
UFO researchers like Bill Moore to
spread disinformation throughout the
entire UFO Community five different
accounts including Dodie's were emailing
from the same internet provider from the
same neighborhood in New Mexico now to
be fair to Dodie he admits to being part
of the disinformation campaign but he
also says that almost everything in the
campaign was true Roswell abductions
underground bases and even the project
serpo Intergalactic Exchange program he
said everything happened when confronted
about the IP address issue he got free
angry and said that he could spoof any
IP address he wanted to well if that's
true why didn't he because in my opinion
before Dodie was exposed closed
captioning not available
[Music]
probably not
even though Richard Doty and the team of
five propagated and added to the serpo
lore a story about an alien Exchange
program has existed since the 1950s or
60s in 2006 when Serpa was lighting up
the UFO forums a user named Chapman
weighed in he said he was formerly of
the British Ministry of defense and said
he saw the serpophiles yes the files
were real but the events described in
them were not Chapman said the original
serpo story was created by Alice Bradley
Sheldon she had a successful career as a
science fiction writer under the
pseudonym James tiptree Jr she published
a lot of books over a lot of years and
was inducted into the science fiction
Hall of Fame she also happened to work
for the CIA during World War II she
worked for military intelligence and
reached the rank of major which was very
high for women at the time after the war
she joined the CIA in the early 60s the
Soviets had successfully convinced the
US government that they had nuclear
weapons hidden on American soil the
nukes were supposedly an abandoned lines
near large American cities and could be
activated by sleeper agents this wasn't
true but it wouldn't be completely
disproved until 1980. project serpo was
a response to this piece of intelligence
the CIA wanted to scare the Russians
into thinking the United States had
acquired advanced technology and was
becoming friendly with aliens and the
Soviets might want to think twice about
detonating a nuclear weapon at first the
serpo story worked the KGB was nervous
but the story became more convoluted and
started to sound like a Cheesy sci-fi
novel this made the KGB suspicious then
the CIA added photographs to the story
the Russians didn't buy it the serpo
story had been forgotten for years but
resurfaced when Richard Doty and the Air
Force perpetrated a very aggressive
disinformation campaign against the UFO
Community the purpose of this campaign
was to flood the community with more and
more outlandish stories eventually UFO
Believers didn't know what was true and
what wasn't some UFO researchers turned
on each other it was chaos and a highly
successful intelligence operation then
over the years Richard Doty goes from
counterintelligence agent to UFO
believer to Keynote speaker at UFO
conventions a part of me wants to
believe him to give Dodie the benefit of
the doubt he claims to this day to have
nothing to do with serpo but if he's
telling the truth why is he making fake
Internet accounts why is he flooding the
internet with the serbo story when
Anonymous AKA Richard Dodie began
posting about serpo the story was simple
but then it got more and more elaborate
Anonymous was even answering questions
from the group what this did was flood
the group with outlandish information
the members didn't know what to believe
and they turned on each other the same
operation Dodie ran in the 80s and the
same result there is no physical
evidence to prove that serpo actually
happened but there's also no evidence to
debunk it we don't know for sure if it
was made up by the CIA whether you
believe it's true or you believe it's
fake it doesn't really matter all we
have are theories we do know that Zeta
reticuli is a binary star system but
it's what's called a wide binary system
the stars are a light year apart so
there's no way that photo is correct
also it's highly unlikely that humans
could eat food on an alien planet in
such a different biome literally
everything would be toxic but Whitley
Shriver Bob Lazar and a few other
whistleblowers say serpo happened Betty
and Barney Hill are maybe the most
famous UFO abductees of all time they
said the aliens who abducted them were
from Zeta reticuli are all these people
lying are they just building on a story
that has evolved over the past 60 years
or is there a Planet out there somewhere
inhabited by an intelligent race of
beings living in peace caring for one
another thinking back fondly on the time
the strange Earth creatures came to
visit and if the evens are real you
can't help but Wonder
what is that alien human hybrid look
like
today's episode is brought to you by one
of the most unique sponsors we've ever
had established titles and that doesn't
sound like VPN software it's not huh
nice change of pace
established titles let you buy as little
as one square foot of land in Scotland
and this allows you to call yourself
Lord or Laird as they say or lady also
established titles plants a tree with
every order and is partnered with great
Charities like one tree planted
hold on what did you just say I could
buy land in Scotland and become a lord
yep you can even use the title on your
credit cards plane tickets online dating
profile yep so I want it well there's
more I want to tell you about this I
want it now
[Music]
and it's my Lord package
I hear it
you're kidding me right
what is this um what is this my Lord if
you don't mind uh you might be taking
this a little bit
okay okay hang on I could
okay
this certifies you as Lord hecklefish
Moriarty and uh this is the plot Number
of your land in Edelson Scotland and uh
they even sent us coordinates Google Map
that I may
site domain
oh this is pretty nice it is I can't
wait to get some surfs out there to work
the land for me and pay me tribute uh
you can't have any serves I shall be a
strict but fair Lord of these lands
myself will come to idolize me you can't
have serfs I could maybe have a few
safes you can't one surf no stop saying
surfs stop saying surfs my Lord all
right but check this out the first 200
people who purchased a title pack using
the promo code twf will get land right
near yours Kingdom Kinda Yeah I shall be
a strict but fair Lord to all who
purchase using promo code twf well you
won't be there Lord there'll be Lords
and Ladies of their own land not for now
but when I raise an Army in coconut land
I shall rule over them and they will
come to know me as a strict but fair
Lord you can't conquer their land then
maybe a marriage pact to strengthen the
kingdom I don't see how that Shelby
truth my eldest son to the daughter of
one of the other Lords we will unite our
kingdoms and my blood shall rule these
lands for a thousand years you have an
eldest son what do you think those guppy
support payments are for Heckle Jr lives
with his mother in Hackensack New Jersey
if you use code twf you'll get an
additional 10 off so go to
establishtitles.com twf you'll be Lord
of your own land you'll get your own
plot number and you get this cool frame
certificate this makes an amazing last
minute gift plus you'll be supporting a
great charity and helping out the
channel and you'll be joining my kingdom
right and that you will come to know me
as a strict
yeah we got it before me get bent it
don't make me declare priminata ugh
gross
[Laughter]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
to learn anything do me a favor like
subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps like most topics we cover
on this channel today's topic was
recommended by you and if there's a
store you'd like to hear or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips a
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible you guys are
amazing and if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon or grabbing something from the
Wi-Fi store coffee mugs are going to be
a collector's item you know you think oh
yeah anything with my face on it is a
sound financial investment I hope you're
right I am well that's gonna do it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you